you
hi everyone is cheering this is video 26
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and yes it's been a while
those of you that have been tracking
this playlist closely it's nearly six
months since the last video but I
certainly have not forgotten about this
series this video here will be the third
and final installment of the basic
checkmate patterns I will be sharing
nine patterns with you you can see them
listed on the right 24 total examples
and as usual I am pulling these just as
I did in the past two videos pulling
them from Lee chess org forward slash
practice so feel free to maybe it try
them on your own first if you would like
I'll have a link in the description so
let's just hop right to it the great
majority of these examples are super
quick and I'll just along the way
provide any visual aids that I think
would be you know useful to your own
game so this first one here noted as the
opera mate basically when you give mate
to your opponent's king when he's on the
back rank and it's the combined effort
of both rook and Bishop so notice the
intersection Square and it's the rook
that simply sweeps down with the support
of the bishop in this case for mate
number two for the opera mate a little
bit more involved but not so much that
we can't work this one out giving up the
Queen and then once again we can note
this little pattern of the rook and
Bishop delivering mate third and final
one for the opera mate this one's a cool
one
kicking out first with a pretty
unexpected move actually Queen to f1
there's only one reply and now we have
this cool double check only one reply
and yet again we can see this
intersection square the bishop and rook
doing the trick for the Opera mate
moving on now to Anderson's mate how to
summarize Anderson's mate it's when you
have a bishop or pawn supporting one of
your major pieces to deliver mate on the
back rank so clearly here we're going to
give me like so example two for
Anderson's mates we want to get our
Queen here and we could do that in a few
moves there's only this silly move to
block us but we will not be stopped from
getting here on our next turn that's me
and one last example for Anderson's made
this one's actually the most
sophisticated of them all for this
particular video yeah if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video see if you can
work out this this checkmate pattern
it's a little bit sophisticated okay
just going to provide the solution now
kicking out first with Knight to e7 note
that if the King moves Queen takes rook
on the very next move is game over
so after this move Queen takes Knight
and now we have this cool move Queen
takes h7 it's really in the end all
these pieces are really focusing in on
the King position that pawn is pinned we
can make use of that fact the king must
go to g8 and once more we see the rook
and Bishop doing the trick in this final
position for Anderson's mate moving on
now to
a dovetail mate funny name
this is when you position your queen
right next to the king and he is well
your queen is 1 squared diagonal from
that king so right here we're going to
have made on the spot and notice that
when you position your queen right next
to the enemy king like this and she is
on a light square she's taking away all
light squares that the King Patek can
potentially run away to so there's only
two dark squares that he could run away
to and those squares are along a file or
rank so that's what you get when you
strike at the king in a along a diagonal
like this he can either go on a file or
rank so it's the little visual thing
Queen the c3 that's the ball game
another example of dovetail me in this
case we can position the Queen on this
dark square once more striking at the
king along a diagonal you can only look
to go to one of these two but the pieces
are in the way so these right here is
our examples of dovetail mates it could
also be the case that you know the enemy
King is not obstructed by his own pieces
but we have these squares under our
control
not the case in this one though Queen f6
is me and this one is a little bit
sophisticated if you could kind of
foresee one day the king being forced to
this Square and we can somehow get our
Queen here we would have another case
where the King is going to be mated and
that's eventually what happens with this
puzzle say checkmate in for kicking off
with Bishop takes pawn and then we have
Queen here it's a little bit involved
check
check and finally we get to go here for
Maine so a queen right next to the king
super-powerful taking away a ton of
squares at most the King will only have
two options assuming you know the Queen
can't be captured safely and this is the
last example of the dovetail mate and
right here the king is not obstructed
we could go here after Queen to d1
that's going to be mate once again
positioning the Queen 1 squared diagonal
from the king and these two are taken
away if you recall from previous basic
checkmate patterns video this is this
specific example is similar to the
Balestra mate
okay moving on now to what's noted as
the Swallowtail mate similar to dovetail
except the Queen is now positioned right
next to the king along a file or rank
and notice that when you're striking at
the king like this he could only try to
escape now along a diagonal so it's kind
of flipped that's just made on the spot
and one last example for swallowtails
mate is positioning the Queen like so
for me
and a cool one this is noted as epilate
three examples here the rooks are
blocking the king that's ball game and
okay this one's a little bit more
elaborate King can't go to these two we
have the knight and Bishop taking away
these two and if only we could get our
rook queen or rook here for me
well this one is ruled out we can't
really go here safely
but we can sack our rook and force
Bishop takes rook and now sneak over
here and this right here is no it's like
a long distance mate surprisingly enough
there's no good move for team light no
way to block and nowhere to run that's
checkmate and one last one for the
epaulette mate these are all taken away
and we're probably seeing the pattern by
now these guys are just in the King's
way Queen d7 and that is game over
moving on to what's noted as suffocation
mate this is the last four patterns now
suffocation in this case we're referring
to the bishop and Knight coordinating
well to deliver the mate the bishop is
taking away squares and the knight in
this case is the one who's delivering
checkmate this one here is starting off
with the bishop check King is very
restricted and now we have a little bit
of a rook in a rook move involved let's
say and there's two different approaches
from this position you could play rook
g3 or Knight to e7 first
Knight to e7 queen takes is forced and
then rook here is May or we can start
with rook here force in Queen takes rook
and then we have the knight in Bishop
doing the trick for this one Greco's May
is next and this is one of the more
practical examples just from my
experience if you're an experienced
player watching this video now I'm sure
you could attest to these this specific
mate the greco mate
it's the bishop is helping out take away
one of the squares right next to the
King there's a a friendly enemy pond
that is well really not so friendly for
black in this case and we need only to
place a major piece somewhere now along
a file so we're all familiar with a back
rank checkmate a Greco's mate may be
another way to view that is like an edge
file may is maybe how you would want to
see the Greco's mate and that's what we
have with Queen h5 and building on that
same idea for Greco's mate in this
example
a night sacrifice and once more the rook
now coming over here for me and one last
example and this is yep this one's
definitely gets my vote for the coolest
one in in this video
double-check
check on g6 and now pawn takes knight
Discoverer check
rook takes Queen in the end will be me
what do you think of that one I really
like that one that one that one's
definitely really cool next just one
example here for llegaste
no nothing more to it than just this
little Lau configuration it's an opening
trap just wanted to show this one real
quick Knight to d5 and yeah all the
squares are taken away from the King you
could look up on YouTube the Gauls mate
and yeah you'll see this many many
videos out there covering this the Gauls
me
and last we have Vukovich Nate three
examples and yeah this is another very
good one just like Greco's mate this one
here yeah Greco's made is very practical
this one
same story rook and knight involved and
one other piece that supports the rook
so in this case the bishop will be
supporting the rook once he's on that e7
square we're going to have mate but in
other cases it could also be maybe a
pawn here or even a king here that are
supporting a move like rook to e7 for
mace so the knight really fulfills the
fulfills the role of restricting and
then that rook is the one that comes in
and drops the final hammer for checkmate
in this case and moving on to second
mate this is a checkmate in three I'll
just throw it to you if you want to
pause the video and work this checkmate
and three out feel free to do that
okay the checkmate in three here once
again highlighting lukovitch's mate is
first Knight to e7 and let me point out
that after this check if the King goes
here we go to this Square and if the
King goes to the corner we would
basically have then well many different
types of mates a back rank mate or even
a type of Arabian mate that was already
covered in previous videos but after
this check the King goes here now the
knight goes here giving check and
defending the rook and finally we're
seeing that the king is the one who's
now assisting rook to f2 for me in this
case and one last example this one here
is a mate in two with Knight to f6
simply rook to g6 and that's really
going to do it this is as mentioned the
third and final installment of the basic
checkmate patterns and as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and I will
catch you hopefully a lot sooner for
video number 27 in this playlist so
that's all for now I hope you're having
a great day and I'll catch you soon take
care bye
you